schön dass du zeit hast was gibt und wo
ist eigentlich mein griffin unten am
wäldchen
also ich würde dir den kaffee ans bett
bringen dich wenn du es jemals schaffen
würde ist vor mir aufzustellen ich
meinte wenn ich hier wohnen würde
schließlich sind meine ganzen sachen
schien alles klar
denn krise sich nicht binden bekommt es
mit mir zu tun
ich bin dann mal weg also raus mit der
sprache
und jetzt hat nicht nichts
ich bin schwanger guten morgen herr
schmiedel
ich habe gerade kaffee aufgesetzt
möchten sie eines hessen
lukas noch gut rausgekommen
alex du wirklich leid wenn unsere
verabredung hat überhaupt kein thema
familie geht doch vor
dann muss man wirklich gern vorsichtig
ständig beim wort was hey das ist doch
wunderschön lotter herzlichen glück ich
weiß überhaupt nicht wann und eigentlich
passen wir auch auf wo ist eigentlich
das problem er liebt euch wohl zusammen
reza kinder
er weiß es nicht
was also nicht von mir denkt hoffentlich
waren weil sie es nicht
ich habe auch keine ahnung
vogel
tut mir leid dass ich dich gestern nach
zu blöd angemacht habe wegen verrat
nicht mache wäre könnte ich dir jetzt
noch eine reinraum
egal was ist ich bin für dich da so
schlecht geschlafen hat mir die wahrheit
du bist schwanger nicht lotter ich bin
nicht schwanger
das war mein sachen deswegen habe ich
ihn jedoch gezeigt den er lügt nicht
raus mit der sprache
warum ist mir nicht so mag gesagt guten
morgen
wenn wir uns nichts dabei gedacht du
liebst mich ihm blind in die arme laufen
ihr versteht euch doch gut das könnte
einen wettbewerbsvorteil sein aber trotz
haben uns ewigkeiten nicht gesehen das
hat ihr fall schief gehen kann
mark hat gemerkt dass ein auftreten
professionell war und dem die
herangehensweise gefallen hat wo ist das
problem
lasst uns gleich aber das projekt
sprechen ja in meinem büro grüße von der
münchen frau zwei zucker kalten nächten
so wie du bist du hast mich heute morgen
überhaupt nicht zu wort kommen lassen
was hältst du eigentlich der fall wenn
wir uns anziehen